este avión aterrizó en el aeropuerto de
estambul a bordo viaja una delegación de
expertos rusos ucranianos turcos y los
representantes de la onu su objetivo
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo para
asegurar la exportación de cereales
desde ucrania tras varios intentos la
confianza es baja especialmente para
kiev aunque el ministro de exteriores
ucraniano espera garantías de seguridad
nos alegraremos de que los barcos
lleguen a nuestros puertos y se marchen
con seguridad para todos tanto para los
transportistas como para los
propietarios de los cereales y también
para nuestros puertos pero para que eso
ocurra tenemos que resolver el problema
de la falta de confianza en rusia porque
ninguno de nosotros ninguno de los
participantes en estas discusiones
confía en rusia
por el momento rusia sigue manteniendo
un bloqueo en el mar negro que va desde
la costa rusa hasta la frontera rumana e
impide la salida de barcos ucranianos
para permitir el paso de los barcos
moscú exige inspecciones y el desminado
de las aguas quien se ha negado hasta
ahora a este último punto en el centro
de los debates está la creación de
corredores marítimos
el tiempo para llegar a un acuerdo sobre
las exportaciones de granos se está
acabando el precio de los alimentos
aumenta lo que hace temer una hambruna
especialmente en áfrica
ucrania es el quinto exportador mundial
de trigo y el cuarto mayor exportador de
maíz el país también representa el 50
por ciento del comercio mundial de
semillas y aceite de girasol por el
momento 20 mil millones de toneladas de
grano ucraniano siguen bloqueadas en los
puertos de la región de odessa turquía
dice que tiene 20 barcos en el mar negro
listos para embarcar las pero todavía no
se ha llegado a un acuerdo